respecter l'environnement tout en
développant les activités
une nouvelle parc sur
vélizy-villacoublay se développent en ce
sens un projet porté par la commune
versailles grand parc et l'afnor et but
c'est de faire un grand réseau est de
faire que ont participé à la croissance
économique et à la création de valeur de
notre pays mais au niveau de l'europe et
au niveau du monde avec les bonnes
démarches et faire en sorte que le
citoyen s'y retrouve que la planète s'y
retrouve et que la croissance de notre
économie soit trop tôt pour penser ce
projet deux modèles chinois basé à pékin
et à jean al de futurs sayoud ce parc de
pékin fondé en 2009 est un projet
d'ingénierie scientifiques et
technologiques et vise 100 mille
personnes bien bernadou j'avais la crise
notre parc le futur science park à pékin
un positionnement très très proche de
l'eee novell parc vélizy il est dans
notre intérêt de partager avec des
lisiers de continuer dans une bonne voie
de l'innovation du web est un ancien
1100 grandes entreprises sont
aujourd'hui installés à lille nouvelle
parquet on peut à près de cinquante
mille personnes des entreprises qui
participent à la conception du quartier
d'affaires